what did the officiants say when you got
married not much when gay marriage was
legalized we weren't sure if or when it
was going to be struck down so speed was
of the essence
and do you kevin yes
and do you yes yes we do
we're married
i remarked afterwards that i wish the
officiant had been more
efficient
it was very funny kevin still talks
about it what's going on a proper
birthday dinner amy chose the restaurant
captain
oh perfect i've always wanted to come
here
boyle pick the menu vivian helped
terry chose the champagne
i'm sorry about your party sir i tried
to keep them in line but i failed well
that's not your job i'm only sorry you
didn't get a chance to enjoy yourself
gina has brought back all the silverware
that she stole from your house
[Music]
what also this clock
good heavens this isn't ours and my
contribution will be to refrain from
discussing the new yorker for the rest
of my living days thank you jake you're
welcome kevin call me kev huh
oh he told you to say that didn't he
well you are always playing pranks on me
raymond just once let me be the funny
one
and finally it is my great pleasure to
introduce the nine-nine zone detective
scully to serenade you
came on yeah
[Applause]
i made kevin this
it's warm it's a croque monsieur kevin
and i shared one on a rainy afternoon in
paris on our first anniversary
it's one of our most treasured memories
tell kevin how you feel
it's raining you could run to him this
is the real world something i know
relationships end in unsatisfying ways
every day
people don't run to each other in the
rain
[Music]
raymond am i too late too late
my friend saw your dating profile and
your photo without collar stays
i thought i'd lost him
you will never lose me
i'll do anything to keep you i'll
compromise on everything the work
nancy myers never fails
now that we're doing it it feels kind of
weird to be staring at your friends
while they kiss are you kidding it's
beautiful
i love you
i love you
marriage is a contract
but it's so much more than that
marriage is love it's
commitment
it's joy
it's understanding it's patience it's
anger
it's reconciliation
it's everything it's like oatmeal
it
sustains you
darlene do you take lynne to be your
lawfully wedded husband i do lin do you
take darlene to be your lawfully wedded
wife i do i now pronounce you husband
and wife you may kiss the bride
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i gotta hand it to you captain that was
some ceremony but it wasn't difficult i
simply said what i wish had been said
when kevin and i got married oh well
then i never would have heard your
hilarious efficient officiant quip
you're right i regret nothing
but all this does make me think i might
enjoy a more festive expression of our
commitment to one another are you
suggesting we hold an honest-to-goodness
wedding
nothing too elaborate we're not the
kardashian west's after all
they are a musician and a celebrity
personality who recently wedded yes yes
i know
they were answers on jeopardy i think
you mean questions
[Laughter]
you guys are fine
we're having a vow renewal ceremony this
time we're pulling out all the stops it
will be a truly extravagant affair oh
how extravagant are we talking champagne
pyramid destination wedding celebrity
officiant we got the salad forks
can you believe it a second fork who do
we think we are
oh no you're shocked at how garish it is
now i don't even want to tell you the
other surprise i have in store for kevin
wait let me guess you're getting bread
plates don't be absurd we're not crazy
there's a lot to do since we decided to
go so over the top i mean look at the
napkins we're going with a pretty
whimsical fold
lengthwise that is
funny the intent was whimsy not humor
now you have me doubting everything
where's where's raymond we're gathered
here to affirm the marriage of raymond
holt and kevin costner we don't have to
do this everyone who's not family has
already gone home and we need to hurry
no this is important
kevin kosner
when we first got married i thought of
it primarily as a legal contract which
is why i memorized the entire federal
tax code
301.7701-180 definitions pertaining to
marriage and yet he can't remember mac's
name but i finally learned what marriage
really is it's not something you can
memorize or an equation you can solve
for it's the feeling you get when you
look in your partner's eyes
and that feeling is all that matters
which is why i will now
purge
tax code
301.7701-180 from my memory so that i
will have room to remember this moment
forever
it's done
hope
raymond holt do you promise to continue
to live in this marriage for richer poor
through sickness and in health as long
as you two both shall live i do and
kevin yes yes we're still married we
really have to go
what do you have to say for yourself the
whole nypd knows where you are and
they're coming for you right now okay
thanks for the tip let's kill them both
get out of here before the cops come
wait no no no no i was lying about the
backup i came alone titled my sex tape
doesn't matter
you're both gonna die now
better get some corticosteroids to treat
that laryngeal fracture sorry i couldn't
bring myself to call him a dirt bag and
why would you a dirtbag is a very useful
part of the vacuum cleaner clearly it's
a compliment oh you guys are so perfect
for each other yeah i stole those coins
i can't believe you bought that old
story they underestimated you randy just
as they underestimated raymond holt you
guys haven't been that great to me
either well you got to teach people how
you want to be treated randy dr phil
r.i.p the point is captain holt solved
the case when no one else could he's
actually been stealing from these
archives for years you've been asleep at
the wheel alastair you're an
embarrassment really well at least i've
never confused scent augustine with
boethius oh who gives a rat's ass about
boethius wesley what are you doing kevin
i'm creating a kerfuffle oh damn sure my
husband is a hot piece of ass but he is
so much more than just that raymond holt
is as smart as anyone in this department
but he chooses to use his intelligence
to make our city a better place
one day i hope to live up to the
standard you set
you make me want to have
a wetter brain
oh kevin
[Music]
y'all are hella specific
you